[Applaudissements]
ça y est
aujourd'hui chez camille verdez faire
une
vous êtes le fer une petite déclaration
c'est possible j'aimerais voilà allez-y
aussi pour soi même rejoindre là oui
bien sûr maintenant voilà à cyril ma
petite chicha j't'aime comme on aime
celui qu'on a cherché éternellement
jusqu à le trouver à ouarzazate
cyril jeu tu es mon coeur tu es mon âme
tu es mon millésime ma plus belle année
cyril c'est pour ça que j'aimerais te
demande est là devant les
téléspectateurs avec tout mon amour avec
toute ma passion avec tous vivent des
vies dans extraordinaire et dans le ça
veut rien dire j'ai va essayer est-ce
que cyril petit couscous royal
tu aimerais qu'on reprenne tous les deux
stoppez pas trop radin plus forts stop
les fatma adda laisse pas avoir par le
direct je veux bien
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]